في الذكرى السنويه الاولى لهذه الحرب نعود
على ابرز ما تناولته الصحف في مثل هذا
اليوم من عام
2022 ونبدا مع صحيفه
ومقال تتحدث فيه عن استعداد اوكرانيا
للغزو الروسي قالت الصحيفه حينها يجب
الاقرار بان سماع الامين العام للامم
المتحده يتحدث عن لحظه خطر والاعلان عن
ازمه اللاجئين جديده ذات حجم استثنائي ليس
مطمئنا الصحيفه تساءلت هل سيكتفي بوتين
بهجوم محدود ام انه سيشرع في حرب شامله
يتم تصور العديد من السيناريوهات وصحيفه
بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا من اعلان
فلاديمير بوتين الى هجمات الجيش الروسي
ظهر الرئيس الروسي على شاشه التلفزيون
ليلقي خطابا مدته 56 دقيقه يمكن تلخيص
جوهره في بعض كلمات لقد قررت اطلاق عمليه
عسكريه وبعد وقت قصير من النطق بهذه
الجمله بدات الانفجارات وصافرات الانذار
تدوي في مدن اوكرانيا وصحيفه اليمانيتي
ايضا عنونه موسكو تختار الاسوا تقول
الصحيفه معطنا الامر بالاجتياح العسكري
للاراضي الاوكرانيه قرر بوتين ان يتحدى
العالم الصحيفه كانت تتساءل حينها الى اي
مدى يمكن ان تتسع هذه الحرب وصحيفه
ليبيغاسيون ايضا عنونه في ازدراء للامم
المتحده فلاديمير بوتين يعلن الحرب مع
انعقاد مجلس الامن الدولي في محاوله يائسه
لتجنب الصراع بين روسيا واوكرانيا يطلق
الكرملين العنان للهجوم العسكري وسط اداره
المجتمع الدولي وصحيفه ايضا عن وانه
الرئيس الاوكراني يتعهد بالدفاع عن البلاد
وروسيا تقول ان الانفصاليين يطلب مساعده
عسكريه الصحيفه تحدثت حينها عن دعوه وجهها
الرئيس الاوكراني للشعب الروسي الى
المساعده في منع الحرب الصحيفه وصفت هذه
المناشده مناشده للروس باليائسه